>> YEAH!
WHERE ARE WE? LOOK AT THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT, HUH?
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT? HAPPY
FRIDAY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS, HIS GUITAR HAS A COUPLE
FOR HIS BEARD. JOHN RICH!
[ CHEERS & APPLAUSE ]
>> HE COULD HAVE BEEN A TV STAR
IF HE WAS NOT SO DAMN LAZY. HOST
OF ONE NATION ON SATURDAY NIGHT
AT 8:00, BRIAN KILMEE. DAVE
RUBAN. [ CHEERS & APPLAUSE ] AND
FINALLY THE STATE OF FLORIDA
CONSIDERS HER AN INVASIVE
SPECIES. FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
CAT.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING, THAT'S
IT FOR TONIGHT. BEFORE WE GET TO
SOME NEWS STORY, LET'S CLEAN UP
THE FRIDGE, SHALL WE?
>> GREG'S LEFT OVER. HMM.
>> YEAH, IT IS TIME ONCE AGAIN
FOR LEFT OVERS. WE DIDN'T READ
THE JOKES WE USED THIS WEEK
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT THEY MAY
HAVE SUCKED. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME I AM READING THESE SO HERE
RWE
P
WE GWE GO.
SMUGGLING COCAINE HID IN THEIR
HAIR EXTENSIONS. IT IS AN STARK
WARNING FOR JOE BIDEN OF THE
DANGER OF SNIFFING WOMAN'S HAIR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND A REMINDER TO HUNTER
BIDEN TO SNIFF WOMAN'S HAIR.
YEAH
P
RYEAH
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> A NEW STUDY IN THE NEW
ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINES
CLAIM THAT UNIVERSAL MASKING MAY
BE AFFECTING IN REDUCING RACISM.
IF THAT'S TRUE, JOY REID SHOULD
BE WEARING IT SIX AT A TIME. [
CHEERS & APPLAUSE ].
>> THIS WEEK, A 5.3 EARTHQUAKE
SHOOK WEST TEXAS. BETO O'ROURKE
WAS SO ALARMED, HE STARTED
YELLING IN ENGLISH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HE LOOKS SO SAD. SCIENTISTS
SAY MALE TESTOSTERONE LEVELS ARE
AT A 40-YEAR LOW BUT HIGHER THN
EVER AMONG FEMALE SWIMMERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS & APPLAUSE ]
>> YEAH, ALL RIGHT. MADONNA, YOU
KNOW HER, RIGHT? RECENTLY POSTED
PICTURES OF HERSELF ON SOCIAL
MEDIA DRINKING WATER OUT OF A
R
DO
DOGGI
DOGGIE
WHEN ASKED WHY, SHE SAID SHE'S
TIRED OF DRINKING OUT OF THE
TOILET
TOI
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT IS AS STEP UP. ACCORDING
TO NEW SURVEY, 9% OF AMERICANS
REMOVED THEIR SHOES AND SOCKS
WHE
WHEN THEY FLY O
AIRCRAFT. IN OTHER WORDS,
TERRORISM IS ALIVE AND WELL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT IS DISGUSTING. SAN
FRANCISCO IS OFFICIALLY LAUNCHED
THE GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAM
FOR MEMBERS OF ITS TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY. THE CITY ALSO
ENCOURAGED BISEXUALS TO APPLY
FOR TWICE THE BENEFITS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH, IT TOOK ME A WHILE BUT I
GET IT. CRYPTO SCAMMER SAM
BANKMENT FREEZE DEMISE IS BEING
COMPARED TO ENRON. SOME EXPERTS
SAY HIS SCAM IS MUCH WORSE
CONSIDERING HE NEVER INVESTED IN
A SINGLE HAIRCUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> JEFFERY DAHMER'S FATHER
REVEALED IN AN INTERVIEW WHAT HE
THINKS MAY HAVE LED HIS SON TO
BECOMING A SERIAL KILLER. HE
SAYS COULD BE SMOKING
CONSIDERING ALL THOSE BUTTS
BEHIND HIS COUCH. WHAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S TOO FAR. WOW!
>> THEY ARE LEFTOVERS.
>> THAT'S WHY WE CALL THEM
LEFTOVERS. OH MY GOD!
>> THAT'S MY FAVORITE ONE.
>> THAT'S YOUR FAVORITE ONE?
>> I AM DISGUSTED BY YOU AND
EVERYTHING. RESEARCHERS FOUND
RATS HAVE SIMILAR RHYTHM TO
HUMANS AND MUSIC FROM LADY GAGA
AND QUEEN, ALTHOUGH RATS HATE
LIZZO BECAUSE SHE NEVER DROPS
ANY FOOD.
>> OH, THAT'S GOOD.
>> BOY, EACH ONE IS MORE
OFFENSIVE THAN THE LAST ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> NEXT YEAR PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY WILL OFFER COURSES IN
BDXM, SEXUALITY AND FETISHISM.
STUDENTS MAJORING IN THE CLASS
WILL STUDY THE WORKS OF RON
JEREMY, YEAH, PRETEND THAT YOU
DON'T KNOW HIM. FINALLY, TWO OF
MY FAVORITE WORDS, AND
FINALLY --
FINALL
FINALLY -
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> CEO ELON MUSK SAYS HE PLANS
TO FIND SOMEONE ELSE TO RUN
TWITTER. I DON'T WANT TO TELL
HIM HOW TO RUN HIS COMPANY BUT I
KNOW SOMEONE WHO'S LOOKING FOR
WORK
P
RWORK
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT WAS A LEFTOVER AND NOW
AS WE FINISH OUR WEEK IN
FLORIDA. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE OTHER BIGGEST THINGS WE
LEARNED WHILE BEING ME. BRIAN
KILMEE HAD A LOWER BACK TATTOO.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> ALTHOUGH IT IS HENA.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
>> THE LIGHTS IS UNCANNING. I
HAD A POST TO THAT.
>> WELL, YOU SHAVED.
>> FLORIDA IS SHOWING THE
COUNTRY HOW TO ENJOY LIFE. THERE
IS LOW TAXES AND TONS OF FUN
THINGS TO DO. I AM NOT THE ONLY
ONE WEARING A THONG. IT IS THE
OPPOSITE IMAGE OF CYNICAL NEW
YORK. THERE IS HIGH TAXES,
PEOPLE ASSAULT OTHERS FOR FUN
AND THE ONLY THONGS YOU SEE ARE
USE
USED AS
USED A
TURNI
SUBWAY. SOMETHING THAT DAVE
RUBIN FIGURED OUT. IT SUCKS OVER
THERE SO THEY MOVED OVER HERE.
DAVE LOOKS AMAZING FOR A MAN IN
HIS 70s. 20 GRAND HE DROPS EAC
WEEK ON STEM CELLS. THE ONLY
BUSINESS BOOMING IN CALIFORNIA
IS U-HAUL. WE SAW IT IS NOT JUST
THE WAY FLORIDA IS RUN, IT IS
THE PEOPLE, TOO. IT IS NOT JUST
A PLACE TO RETIRE ANYMORE, IT IS
A PLACE TO HAVE A LITTLE HELL
AND HAVE FUN. THAT STUFF REALLY
WORKS. THEY DON'T PAY ME TO SAY
THAT. BUT, THEY PROBABLY WILL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL RIGHT, THE BEST PART
ABOUT THIS WEEK WAS OUR AWESOME
FANS. I WANT YOU TO CHECK OUT
THIS MOMENT FROM WEDNESDAY'S
NIGHT SHOW
NIGHT SHOW. TAKE
>> SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
USE DONALD TRUMP AND SAY IT IS
MEGA-TRUMP AND NO ONE THINKS
THEY WANT TO VOTE. THE AMAZING
PART AND I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT IVANKA BECAUSE I DO KNOW
HER. SHE'S AN INCREDIBLE MOTHER.
SHE REALLY IS. AS WEALTHY AND
SUCCESSFUL THEY ARE, SHE'S CLOSE
TO HER KIDS.
>> [ LAUGHTER ]
>> I AM UNDER THE ASSUMPTION
THAT THEY ARE TOGETHER.
>> THEY ARE NOW. BY THE WAY, IT
IS FUNNY BUT WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THAT FINGER BEEN.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW --
>> IT IS FLORIDA. SO YOU DON'T
SEE THAT SORT OF THING ON
SPECIAL REPORT. NO WONDER BRETT
BEAR HATES ME. I AM NOT LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING OUT OF HERE
BECAUSE I KNOW ONCE I LEAVE, I
AM GOING TO FEEL OLDER, I SHOULD
HAVE STAYED AT THE VILLAGES.
>> YEAH, THE SEX WAS TOO GOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH!
ALL RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> JOHN RICH, YOU'RE A TENNESSEE
GUY, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
FLORIDA? ANY INSIGHTS BEFORE I
LEAVE AND YOU LEAVE OR PERHAPS
WE LEAVE TOGETHER PRIVATELY?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> LIKE WE ALWAYS DO?
>> YES.
>> WELL, YOU WHINE UP IN MY
HOUSE HALF OF THE TIME WHEN WE
LEAVE. FLORIDA SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF, YOU SEE PEOPLE COMING IN
THERE EVERYWHERE FOR A REASON.
THE PATRIOT WAR AND THE
FLORIDIANS WERE ALIVE AND WELL.
IT WAS ROCKING, MAN.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT IS AN INCREDIBLE EVENT. WE
GAVE THE AWARD AWAY. IT WAS A
DOWNER FOR ME BECAUSE I HAD NOT
BEEN NOMINATED FOR ANYTHING.
NOTHING.
I THINK I AM THE REAL HERO,
BRIAN.
>> THOUGH YOU LOVE FLORIDA
ALMOST AS MUCH AS FLORIDA HATES
YOU.
>> REALLY?
>> THIS IS FROM THE GALLUP POLL.
IT IS CALLED PEOPLE WHO ARE
REPULSED BY BRIAN KILMEE FROM
THE YEAR 2002 AND 2022. ITS GO
EIGHT AUTHORS AND THERE ARE SOME
CHARTS HERE. OH MY GOODNESS,
THEY REALLY HATE YOU, BRIAN. DO
YOU WANT FOX TO MOVE US DOWN
HERE? [ CHEERS & APPLAUSE ].
>> THEY WANT TO MOVE DOWN HERE.
NUMBER ONE IS NOT ALL FLORIDIANS
THAT CAME OUT. PEOPLE FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY COME OUT FOR
A BREAK AND THEY MAY NOT LEAVE.
THE PROBLEM IS IF EVERYONE FROM
NEW YORK DID NOT LEAVE, LEE
ZELDIN WOULD HAVE WON. HE GOT
40% OF THE VOTES WHEN EVERY ONE
OF THE OTHER THREE PEOPLE WERE
REPUBLICANS AND NO ONE KNEW WHO
HE WAS. THAT'S HOW QUICK. ALL OF
YOU PEOPLE DEFECTED, GO BACK
QUICK AND HAVE LEE ZELDIN DEMAND
A RECOUNT AND SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO.
>> THAT'S SO TRUE. IT IS AN
INTERESTING THING. IT IS MY
INSANITY THEORY. THE SAME PEOPLE
LEAVE AND THE INSANE PEOPLE STAY
SO YOU ONLY REELECT THE SANE
PEOPLE. RIGHT, DAVE? IS THAT WHY
YOU LEFT LOS ANGELES AND COME TO
FLORIDA?
>> I LIVE IN MIAMI AND GREG,
WHEN WE DO YOUR SHOW IN NEW
YORK, YOU HAVE TO DRUG THE
AUDIENCE BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
DEPRESSED FROM LIVING IN NEW
YORK. WATCH THIS, MAKE SOME
NOISE FOR THE FREE STATE OF
FLORIDA HERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LOOK AT THIS!
HAPPY. HAPPY PEOPLE POWERED BY
FLORIDA'S ORANGE JUICE AND
FREEDOM.
>> YES, YES. [ CHEERS & APPLAUE
].
>> I LIKE TO GIVE YOU THE 2022
VERSION OF ANITA BRYANT.
>> YOU REALIZE THESE PEOPLE ARE
HAPPY AND THEY JUST GOT HIT BY
TWO HURRICANES.
>> AMAZING. DID YOU SEE HOW FAST
THEY REBUILT THE ROAD?
>> IT IS AMAZING. THEY BUILT A
BRIDGE.
>> IT WOULD TAKE US FIVE YEARS
IN NEW YORK TO COME UP WITH THE
PLANS OR TAX.
>> WE CAN'T BUILD A DOUBLE TREE.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S SAD. THAT'S HIS
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS, CAT. ARE
YOU GLAD TO SEE BRIAN IN MIAMI.
IT IS LIKE YOU CAN'T GET AWAY
FROM HIM.
>> EXCUSE ME -- I HAVE EXTENDED
MY STAY.
>> ANYTHING? I JUST REALIZED
THAT I HAVE BEEN HERE SINCE
WEDNESDAY AND I HAVE NOT BEEN
OUTSIDE YET.
>>
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO THA.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN TO THE CASINOS?
>> NO, I DON'T GAMBLE. I DID THE
SLOTS WHEN I WAS YOUNGER AND I
WON $300 AND I NEVER WON AGAIN.
RP
>
>> YOU GAMBLE
>> WELL, EVERY TIME WE OPEN OUR
MOUTH IS A GAMBLE. I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT HAD GONE ON THIS
LONG. YOU ARE NEAR RETIREMENT
AGE?
>> YOU THINK THAT JOKE WOULD BE
NEAR RETIREMENT AGE.
>> WOW.
>> WOW, THAT WAS UNNECESSARY.
>> REALLY?
>> NO, IT WAS NECESSARY.
>> I DESERVE IT.
>> YOU ARE NEW YORKERS AND SO
YOU ARE - AND MOANING ABOUT
NOTHING
NOTHING. [ CHE
>> THAT'S SO TRUE.
>> WE ARE IN FLORIDA NOW, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
EVERY LITTLE THING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO GO OUTSIDE
THEN I WILL REMEMBER IT.
>> I WILL GO TO THE GREEN ROOM,
WHAT A WONDERFUL DAY, HARD ROCK
HOTEL AND FOX AND EVERYONE IS
HAPPY.
>> OH, I KNOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY, YOU KEEP THAT NEW YORK
UP NORTH, YOU HEAR ME?
>> WHAT'S WORSE THOUGH, DIARRHEA
OR HAVING TO HEAR ABOUT HIS
DIARRHEA NON-STOP? FROM THE
MOMENT I WOK